plaisir face à rosny-sur-seine c'était
l'une des affiches de ces huitièmes de
finale de la coupe des yvelines deux
équipes qui évoluent en d2 de district
les visiteurs du nord du département
ouvre la marque dans les premières
minutes du match sur cette action mais
l'avantagé de courte durée et jours de
plaisirs arrive à combiner et pousse le
défenseur à la faute un partout les
plaisirs wa marque une nouvelle fois
juste avant la pause dehors au moins on
marque assez tôt dès raids ailleurs que
ça nous met en confiance et après je te
réponde à un abus de confiance donc on
joue moins bien et apprend donc dans nos
travers mais la première mi temps ça va
dans l'ensemble ça va dans les deux
premiers buts qui les lancent dans le
match et inscrire ce point que première
mi-temps assez mitigées avec un terrain
catastrophique on devait jouer sur le
synthétique mais ils étaient inondés
donc on a à jouer sur le sueur sur le
terrain en herbe terrain un terrain
catastrophique comme voulait le dis avec
beaucoup de faux rebonds on est une
équipe qui joue au ballon là on a dû
déjouer avec des longs ballons en
seconde période plaisir semble mieux
apprivoiser le terrain 45 minutes à sens
unique où les locaux plus frais
physiquement arriverons a marqué à deux
reprises quinze minutes après le retour
des vestiaires puis cinq minutes plus
tard le score est sans appel 4 1 à la
fin des 90 minutes on avait à coeur de
commencer bien 2022 on savait que en
coupons c'était notre domaine de
prédilection
si on a fait un grand parcours en coupe
de france on se fait éliminer par une 3e
penalty et donc la huitième de finale il
fallait qu'on rapporte ce match on
savait que c'était un match éliminatoire
butoir donc on a fait un match assez
prolifique en buts avec 4 buts à notre
actif direction à présent les quarts de
finale pour le club avec un objectif en
tête ramener la coupe à la maison le
prochain match est programmé le 20
février